Mike Pence and mayor Pete had a big spat
this week I don't know if you heard
about this Mike mayor Pete said if you
have a problem with me being a
homosexual take it up with my creator
and Mike Pence was like oh no we're the
only one that gets to use the god
argument and Mayor Pete was like well if
you're so Christian how come you're a
supporter of that long adulterous porn
star so we thought this would be
a perfect week to do something we do
hear a lot on the show 25 things you
don't know about me it's really
something from we stole it from US
magazine but we do it better so now we
own it okay 25 things about Mike Pence
you don't know I played the pilot in
every airline safety video Karen I
waited until marriage to have eye
contact
the stick up my ass is made from
repurposed driftwood my wife teaches at
an anti-gay school but that doesn't make
her anti-gay although she is anti I can
I can identify brands of white bread
just by smelling them if I could change
one thing in the Bible I'd make Jesus
wear a shirt I called bagels do
doughnuts
[Applause]
I'm so homophobic I eat bananas sideways
whenever I see a rainbow I throw rocks
at it and say be gone Jair
and I won't even use the back door to my
house
you